alors pour un peu plus de musique de
deux solutions soit vous allez voir le
spectacle c'est la meilleure solution
soit vous regarder demain soir champs
elysées avec michel drucker puisque
michel seurat michel berger sera reçue
chez michel drucker alors une question
inédite
n'est ce pas pourquoi avoir refait ce
qui était bien fait au cd fait d'une
certaine manière mais c'était aussi
d'une partie de notre vie on avait envie
d'aller jusqu'au bout ça a été fait 2-2
autrefois au canada c'était recréer
encore à montréal une fois et une autre
front l'avait envie de donner une
version un petit peu à nous ce qu'on a
fait la mise en scène est qd plamondon
oui c'est vrai que cette fois-ci vous
vous êtes occupé de tout six jours et
c'est très excitant parce qu'on peut
donner vraiment une idée globale de ce
que de ce qu'on a dans la tête qu'il
avait découvert des choses
d'abord on a découvert une génération de
chanteurs qui est formidable
ça veut dire combien d'audition ça veut
dire un travail fait au canada ou au
québec un peu partout il ya trois
personnes qui trois comédiens qui est
qu'ils ont joué au canada
et puis en france on a écouté beaucoup
de cassettes et et on a écouté beaucoup
de gens et moi j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait c'était beaucoup plus facile
maintenant il ya dix ans et par rapport
à la première version donc il y a dix
ans et s'il ya des choses qui avaient
vieilli dans le texte ou dans
l'interprétation ou dans la musique on a
eu le temps si vous voulez au fur et à
mesure qu'ils puissent qui lui trois
fois starmania de change et des petites
choses de resserrer des choses il y
avait un personnage de gourou qui était
très 1970 ce qu'on a fait disparaître
par exemple mais le fond du sujet que
plamondon a écrit qui est la
médiatisation à outrance et le lait les
villes des souterrains ça c'est vraiment
le monde d'aujourd'hui alors qu'à dix
ans c'était le monde de demain
j'ai vu que vous aviez un oeil ironique
est donc salutaire sur la télévision et
en particulier les présentateurs de jt
mais oui ce que l'histoire est racontée
entre autres par un présentateur de
journal si vous me permettez
l'expression bien barge celui là celui
là aussi il a beaucoup qui vous avoue
que regarder
je dirais comme ça vous n'êtes pas
obligé tout le manger c'était
intéressant son travail ça a été de se
trouver les petits tics des gens qui
présente le journal alors que l'autre
mais la conversation nous venons d'avoir
va faire les beaux jours nos camarades
de la presse écrite qui note tout très
bien
en tout cas vous êtes satisfait de ce
qui s'est passé hier soir c'est
parfaitement au point très heureux
j'espère que les gens nés en tout cas
c'est c'est vraiment une aventure pour
nous très bien alors on rendu qu il ya
dix ans votre ami daniel balavoine kutxa
pourri hommage vous en reparlerez avec
michel drucker et puis là quelques
quelques nouveaux dont certains on
connaissait quand même au radon l'avait
déjà entendu c'est vrai c'est vraiment
beaucoup qu'on va découvrir je crois
aussi très bien alors maintenant on a
dit par ordre alphabétique nous en
arrivons à l'aide